and that's where we begin this hour now
if you've seen any of Sebastian's
stand-up routines you know he spends a
lot of time sharing funny stories about
his experience as a dad
my wife first got pregnant everybody was
asking us are you gonna take photographs
of the ballet
and doing a noun
Anonymous
I said no we're just gonna tell people
this is it she's right there
you've seen these guys
are these pregnancy announcements
the husband oh Michelle's over here
dying right now uh Sebastian dad's a
five-year-old Seraphina and
three-year-old Caruso has teamed up with
pediatrician Dr Scott Cohen the author
of Eat Sleep poop their parenting
podcast is called daddy versus doctor
and they're sharing advice and their own
parenting Adventures take a look
today we're sitting here with Claudia a
single mother by choice of twins Chloe
and Enzo and she's struggling
introducing food to them and we want to
see what is going on in Claudia's house
let's take a look
[Music]
fertilization I put two embryos on I got
twins it was just a dream came true to
be a mom
some food it's challenging because I
have to see them at the same time oh
come on it's
nice and salt to eat but Chloe on the
other hand she has a very good appetite
like Mama and she just loves food
first I started just one meal a day and
then I went up to two meals a day Chloe
doesn't like zucchini but I feel it's
healthy and it's a veggie and I'm trying
to feed them lots of veggies I know
eventually my twins will have to grab
the food and eat them on their own but I
am way too scared to do that yet okay
okay sometimes one is hungry the other
one is not hungry but I try to put them
on the same schedule or else I'll drive
myself crazy
now being a father of a five-year-old
and a three-year-old I could sympathize
with you when it comes to introducing
foods to kids is this something that
you're seeing as a big concern amongst
the parents at your practice I do I
think the hardest part about having
twins with everything whether it's
development or feeding is that you have
a direct comparison and we see that
comparison is one is normal and one is
abnormal when in reality it's usually
they're both are normal but different
yeah Atlanta my wife is is a lot more
like oh give them a strawberry give them
a grape and I went to they're gonna
choke mince it up it was up to me I'd be
you know giving them parade until
they're 18.
Enzo's having problems eating now what I
used to do with my kids I used to take
the fork right and I used to load up the
plane and then I would actually have a
Runway with this guy and just take off
and I would run around the house
with the food and then come and it was
beautiful who do you think had more fun
him or Caruso I think him are you doing
but are you doing any dive mammers right
into the yeah yes it works it works make
feeding fun but if they don't want it
you also don't have to force it
it's funny because we spend our whole
childhood as parents trying to get our
child to gain weight and we try to spend
our whole adulthood losing weight so I
wish it was the reverse there's another
thing I grew up around the kitchen table
with my family eating nowadays it just
seems like kids are eating at 4 35. I
ain't hungry at five o'clock in the
afternoon right my wife and I put the
kids to bed and we eat around 8 8 30. is
there something to be said about you
sitting down with the kid she's she's
doing it at the same time like the twins
I think having a meal time with the
family is a good thing to establish a
routine and have that repetition but
that feeding period may be very short
you know they may not be interested it's
like all right good we're done we'll try
again later chicken and mushrooms
do you make food and if they don't eat
it that's it I make food if they don't
eat in then they don't eat it but I do
feel guilty with feeding or anything
else we compare ourselves to other
people and it always seems like
everybody's doing it better than us and
that's not the case you'll start trying
little bits of finger foods and let them
decide let them run the show and they'll
grow and do great my kid was eating
apples
in the bed today my wife's a little bit
more lenient when it comes to rules
she's five years old she's eating apples
in my bed in a little bowl we don't eat
apples in bed we sleep in bed right do
you sleep on the kitchen table no what
do you think it is
okay yeah I gotta agree I'm gonna go
ahead and rubber stamp that I'm living
that right now but this bad memory is
coming back for you guys yeah you're a
good cook you're telling me your kids
don't eat your food they spit that food
out my my son will eat only things that
are plain plain plain but we're gonna
get into that maybe there's some tricks
yeah my kid had hot sauce on everything
everything really now but they were
little that's that southern palette
right yeah I'm telling you just ahead
Sebastian Maniscalco and Dr Scott Cohen
will join here they are live with some
parenting tips for families with picky
eaters like mine and probably yours look
at that sweater Sebastian oh yeah he's
rocking it we see him matching the logo